au 1er janvier 2020 la france compte 35
mille 54 communes 90% d'entre elles ont
moins de trente deux mille habitants et
depuis 1884 elles sont gérées par le
conseil municipal et par le maire elles
ont à leur charge de nombreuses
compétences la plus connue c'est sans
doute la gestion de l'état civil la
mairie enregistre les mariages les
naissances et les décès et c'est aussi
en mêlée que vous devez vous rendre pour
renouveler votre carte d'identité à
condition que la mairie soit équipé
d'une station d'enregistrement
à noter aussi que ce sont les communes
qui organisent les élections qu'il
s'agit des révisions des listes
électorales la gestion des bureaux de
vote ou encore les envois des résultats
en préfecture
la commune a aussi compétence en matière
de sécurité le maire est le garant de
l'ordre public il doit assurer le bon
ordre la tranquillité et la salubrité
publique il est aidé par la police
municipale ou les gardes champêtres
quand il s'agit d'une zone rurale il
exerce ses pouvoirs sous le contrôle
administratif du préfet et du tribunal
administratif
du côté de l'enseignement primaire la
ville est propriétaire des locaux des
écoles publiques établies sur son
territoire c'est à dire qu'elle en
assure la construction les grandes
réparations mais aussi leur entretien
elle organise la restauration scolaire
dont elles fixent la participation
financière des familles elle gère aussi
les personnels non enseignants comme les
atsem peut-être un peu moins connus la
compétence liés à l'urbanisme la commune
élabore le plan local d'urbanisme le
fameux pl lui la commune peut par
exemple décidé d'empêcher des
constructions pour des raisons
architecturales historique et elle
délivre aussi les permis de conduire
voilà une petite liste non exhaustive de
compétence de la mairie